* Hupen *
* Fliessender Indie-Rock-Song *
# Don't look at me like this,
hun, don't be upset.
# What a wonderful day.
# Don't be mad at me
because I feel alright.
# I can't be happy
if you're not alright.
# Don't worry
cause I really feel alright.
# I go to the USA.
* Leise Stimmen aus dem Radio *
Es ist das erste Mal, dass ich
in den Vereinigten Staaten bin.
Es ist ein bisschen wie im Film.
Überall ist ständig Musik,
auch die Werbung ist lustig,
z.B. Werbung für Anwaltskanzleien -
völlig anders als in der Schweiz.
Hier machen sie Werbung mit Emojis.
Jetzt sitze ich
im Uber Richtung Campus.
Es ist etwas stressig,
wie jedes Mal zu Semesterbeginn.
Man fragt sich,
ob man Freunde finden wird,
ob man richtig angezogen ist,
ob der eigene Stil ankommt.
Die UCLA ist Laurianes Traum.
Lauriane, die Internationale
Beziehungen in Genf studiert,
geht für ein Semester an die
renommierte University of California.
Voila, je ...
Die erste Knacknuss
im Campus-Labyrinth:
ihr Zimmer zu finden.
Ich weiss nicht recht,
wo ich hingehen soll.
Vielleicht dort drüben.
Ich versuch's hier.
Geschlossen.
Okay. Hello.
Ich habe die ID,
aber den Zimmerschlüssel nicht.
Da ist es. Wir sind hier.
Yeah.
- Das ist das Stadion.
Gehen Sie da entlang! Da ist es.
Erster Stock, Zimmer 123.
Es ist riesig!
- Oh, yeah.
Behalten Sie den Plan!
- Danke.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Wir sind auf der Küstenstrasse
nach Santa Monica,
fahren in nördliche Richtung
nach Malibu.
Herr Goldsmith wohnt
zwischen Malibu und Santa Monica,
in Pacific Palisades.
Mein Kunde, Richard Goldsmith,
ist Produzent und Präsident
einer französischen Firma,
die Fernsehserien für Kinder macht.
Ein Riese mit weichem Herz,
das ist Randy.
Er ist vor 28 Jahren
aus Liebe zum American Football
aus Lugano in die USA gekommen.
Dann hat er sein Glück
beim Film versucht,
seiner zweiten grossen Leidenschaft -
ein kurzes Zwischenspiel.
Der Branche ist er treu geblieben,
aber er hat in die zweite Reihe
gewechselt, hinter die Stars.
Meine Arbeit
ist nicht immer dieselbe.
Manchmal fahre ich,
bin Privatchauffeur,
manchmal bin ich
mit einer Hollywoodgrösse unterwegs
und arbeite als Bodyguard.
Schön, dich zu sehen!
Was einen guten Bodyguard ausmacht?
Du musst gut gebaut sein, so wie
ich, 2 m gross, breite Schultern.
Hast du viel zu tun?
Ich gehe an die Oscars
für Millstein, den Typen von Disney.
Er war sich nicht sicher,
wollte mir noch Bescheid geben,
aber wahrscheinlich geht er.
Disney hat zwei Filme im Rennen:
"Die Unglaublichen 2"
und "Ralph reicht's 2".
Gehst du morgen
an die Grammy-Verleihung? - Was?
Gehst du an die Grammys?
- Nein. Mal schauen.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Frühaufsteherin Dora
umgeht den höllischen Morgenverkehr
in der Stadt der Engel.
Sie träumt
von einem funktionierenden ÖV.
Ich nehme in Zürich
eigentlich sehr gerne das Tram -
und in der Schweiz den Zug.
Ich vermeide ...
Meine Schwester versteht das nicht:
"Nimm das Auto!" "Nein, danke."
Die Menschen hier
haben sehr wenig Zeit füreinander,
denn sie arbeiten
wahnsinnig viele Stunden,
und es ist kompliziert,
jemanden zu besuchen -
wegen des Verkehrs und allem.
Man hat einfach keine Zeit.
Die meisten arbeiten, sind zu Hause,
schlafen und gehen wieder arbeiten.
Wenn sie Kinder haben,
geben sie sich mit den Kindern ab.
Aber im Allgemeinen
vereinsamen die Menschen ein wenig.
Auch dafür ist Tanz gut.
Auch Orte ... Wie sagt man?
Drama und so,
das an der Schule gelehrt wird.
Das ist gut. Man lernt wieder,
miteinander zu verkehren.
L.A. breitet sich aus
wie ein Krake seine Tentakel.
Kein Stadtkern,
nur Quartiere und Regionen,
über denen Fahnen
aus aller Herren Länder wehen.
Die Stadt samt Agglomeration
ist riesig.
20 Mio. Menschen
leben ihr Abenteuer in der Metropole,
die sich zwischen Ozean
und Gebirgsketten ergiesst.
Im Herzen des Häusermeeres
liegt Hollywood,
Sehnsuchtsort
für Stars und Sternchen.
Die Traumfabrik lockt.
Wer sich auf sie einlässt,
gewinnt oder geht unter.
Ob schäbig oder schillernd,
ob Show oder Schicht,
in Los Angeles kann es
jede und jeder zu etwas bringen.
In der Regel kommen die
4'400 Schweizerinnen und Schweizer,
die hier leben, ganz gut klar.
Wie geht's? Freut mich.
I'm Camryn.
- Nice to meet you. Lauriane.
Endlich ein herzliches Willkommen
von Camryn,
einer der beiden Zimmergenossinnen.
Das hier ist dein Bett.
Das sind Pflanzen, die mir
meine Freunde überlassen haben.
Schön, ich liebe Pflanzen.
Und falls du
noch kein Bettzeug hast,
kannst du erst mal das hier nehmen.
- Vielen Dank.
Bis später.
- Ja, danke.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, too.
15 m2 zu dritt,
das Bad auf dem Flur -
in L.A. wird man erfinderisch.
Ich weiss nicht,
welcher Schrank meiner ist.
Ich denke, der hier wird es sein.
Das Zimmer
habe ich mir kleiner vorgestellt.
Das ist schon mal
eine gute Überraschung.
Ich habe nicht erwartet,
einen Schreibtisch zu haben.
Ich fühle mich wohl. Meine
Zimmergenossin ist sympathisch.
Sie hat mir
zwei, drei Dinge erklärt.
* Geschäftige, elektronische Musik *
Den Pelikanen zusehen
und gleichzeitig Pläne entwerfen?
Niemand
hätte auf Rogers Traum gesetzt.
Und doch
hat der 50-jährige gebürtige Bündner
die Zweifler in seinem Umfeld
Lügen gestraft.
In Los Angeles
hat er sein Fundament gelegt.
Ich bin nach Los Angeles gekommen,
weil ich eine Ausbildung machen,
weiter zur Schule gehen wollte.
Ich habe an der UCLA
einen Master in Architektur gemacht.
Danach wollte ich eigentlich
in die Schweiz zurückfahren,
aber das tat ich dann nicht.
Life gives you things,
und am Ende bist du immer noch hier.
Das war vor 20, nein, 22 Jahren.
Anfangs konnte ich
knapp meine Rechnungen zahlen.
Es ging gerade so auf,
aber eigentlich ...
Ja, am Ende blieb nichts übrig.
Ich wohnte in Venice Beach
in einer gang neighbourhood.
Ich hatte für 500 $ im Monat
ein Zimmer gemietet.
Mein Auto wurde gestohlen.
In retrospect,
wenn man zurückschaut,
war es eigentlich eine gute Sache -
im Moment vielleicht nicht,
aber du lernst hustlen,
wie man bei uns in Los Angeles sagt.
Du lernst, rauszugehen
und Jobs zu finden.
Als ich damals die Schweiz verliess,
sagten alle:
"No way, dass du dort
ein Architekturbüro eröffnen
oder auch nur
zur Schule gehen kannst."
Das war damals schon:
"No way, dass du dort
eine Uni besuchen kannst."
Weil ich nicht den normalen
Architekturwerdegang habe,
wie man ihn in der Schweiz macht,
mit ETH und so -
ich habe
einen anderen Weg eingeschlagen.
Darum hiess es:
"Du hast keine Chance."
Bei manchen löst das aus,
dass man den Zweiflern
erst recht beweisen will,
dass es geht. I can do it.
* Antreibende Westerngitarre *
Ich kam 1995 nach Los Angeles.
Ich habe einen Master
an der UCLA gemacht.
Ich bin mit einem One-Way-Ticket
hier angekommen.
* Stakkatoartiges Hupen *
Es gab einen Professorenstreik.
Sie kämpften für besseren Lohn
und eine Krankenversicherung.
Stell dir das mal vor:
Lehrkräfte,
die keine Krankenversicherung haben!
Es war ein ziemlicher Schock,
als ich hier ankam.
Ich habe die Stadt
überhaupt nicht verstanden.
Da gab's kein Zentrum, ich wusste
nicht, wohin ich gehen sollte,
um Leute zu treffen
oder einen Kaffee zu trinken.
Ich wusste gar nichts.
Schritt für Schritt habe ich mich
in dieser Stadt eingelebt,
die trotz allem schwierig bleibt.
Dann habe ich mich in sie verliebt.
Ich glaube,
weil sie so schwer zu erobern war,
habe ich dann Ja zu ihr gesagt.
In ihrem Atelier
im Industriegebiet Atwater
nimmt Francesca den Raum ein,
den sie in der Schweiz nie hatte.
Ihren rebellischen Geist,
den sie in der Genfer
Hausbesetzerszene erprobt hat,
hat sie behalten.
Ich gehöre zu den Leuten,
die in Genf
das Ilot 13 und den Etat d'Urgences
gegründet haben,
also auch damals schon
politische Ideen hatten.
Und auch wenn ich
in einer Gemeinschaft gelebt habe,
die sehr offen war,
musste ich die Wurzeln kappen,
um mich entfalten zu können.
Ich glaube, dass meine Bilder
immer schon etwas
von zerfallener Architektur hatten,
von Notunterkunft, von Nest.
Das zieht sich wie ein roter Faden
durch meine Malerei.
Aber es stimmt auch,
dass sie mit Aktionen begonnen hat,
und erst als ich hierhergezogen bin,
ist sie bildhafter geworden.
Eine Entwicklung,
die anerkannte Galerien
wie Hauser & Wirth gerne begleiten.
Während sich die Kunstwelt
permanent vorwärts bewegt,
sind die Ideen der Regierenden
regelmässig rückwärtsgewandt.
(Frau im Radio)
... can't sell his beer.
No more beers? Fuck Trump!
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
* Klassische Klaviermusik *
(Dora) Fersen, und atmen!
Elastisch ziehen! Gut.
Auch mit 72 Jahren brennt Dora
für das Vermitteln und Weitergeben.
Die Tänzerin und Choreografin
aus Zürich
hat ihre Spitzenschuhe auf allen
grossen Bühnen der Welt geschnürt.
Sie hat an der ehrwürdigen
Metropolitan Opera
in New York unterrichtet
und ohne Zögern
ans Community College gewechselt -
ein Konservatorium,
das allen offensteht.
Das ist keine harmonische Bewegung,
das ist: ta-da-ara.
Wie auf der Achterbahn,
hoch und runter.
Du tauchst ab ins Tal,
und da gibt es diesen Moment,
du erstarrst,
du berührst das Universum,
du holst all deine Energie raus.
Denk an da Vinci!
And up! Go! And up! Align!
Ich arbeite gern mit den Schülern
und gebe gern Stunden,
v.a. Ballett.
Choreografie
und dann die rehearsals ...
Wie sagt man?
Die Proben für die Show.
Wir haben zweimal im Jahr eine Show,
und die habe ich jetzt
lange geleitet.
Excellent.
Ich bin wahnsinnig stolz auf Carol.
Sie ist 80 ...
... und macht alles
und ist wirklich gut.
Und Bernie ist 60.
Das ist besser.
Lass uns zählen!
And one, two and push! Go! And ...
Ich habe z.B. George Chakiris ...
Er hat ja den Oscar
für "West Side Story" erhalten.
Janis Ian war
eine berühmte Sängerin-Songwriterin.
Wir sind immer noch befreundet.
Ja, viele. Sämtliche Tänzer
der Shows sind zu mir gekommen.
Ich hatte v.a. Professionelle.
Spürst du das?
Streck dich, berühr das Universum!
Patrick Swayze hat auch meine
Klasse besucht. Er war auch hier.
Und noch andere.
Ich muss das mal aufschreiben,
damit ich mich an alle erinnere.
Elbow touches
the rim of the universe.
And one, two and three.
Release! Let go! Lass los!
Thank you.
That worked.
Heute erteilt sie
eine ihrer allerletzten Tanzstunden,
denn Dora will nach 40 Jahren
in den Vereinigten Staaten
in die Schweiz zurück.
Heimweh kennt Dora nicht.
Ich hatte im Leben
ja viele Veränderungen.
Ich habe an vielen Orten
in vielen Ländern gewohnt,
und es hat mir eigentlich
nie viel ausgemacht, zu wechseln.
Ich habe mich immer darauf gefreut.
Das Leben muss weitergehen.
Darum macht's mir vielleicht
auch nicht so viel aus,
jetzt wieder weiterzugehen.
Ich habe für mich dieses Recht
immer beibehalten,
dass ich weitergehen kann
und nicht irgendwo stecken bleibe.
Und das ist gut so.
Man muss loslassen können.
Es ist Zeit, loszulassen.
Jetzt gehen wir auf den 405,
die längste Parking ...
... den längsten Parkplatz der Welt.
Hier ist es immer schlimm,
wenn man vom 90er-Freeway kommt.
Bevor man zum 10er-Freeway kommt,
gibt es immer einen Engpass.
Das ist jeden Morgen so.
Es ist den ganzen Tag so.
* Brummende elektronische Musik *
In Los Angeles
ist Autofahren die Hölle.
Zu Spitzenzeiten endet das Roadmovie
eingekeilt in einer Blechlawine.
Die Wegzeiten richtig einzuplanen,
gehört zu Rogers Stärken.
Er fährt ungehindert
in den östlichen Teil der Stadt.
Ein treuer Kunde hat ihn
mit dem Bau seines Hauses betraut.
Mit der Mauer können die Bäume
nicht bleiben. Einer liegt schon.
Doch zuerst
braucht er eine Baubewilligung.
Das ist das Problem.
- Muss es die Stadt ersetzen?
Sie werden es nicht tun,
wegen der Kosten.
Ich schau mit dem Verantwortlichen,
ob wir die Dinge nicht
andersherum machen könnten.
Was kompliziert ist.
Roger stösst an die Grenzen
des kalifornischen Traums.
Es ist ein schwieriges property,
weil es in einer gully ist -
der tiefste Punkt.
Das ist kein guter Baugrund.
Man muss piles einlassen,
um die foundation zu machen.
Da dauert es länger,
eine Baubewilligung zu bekommen.
Aber heute ist es normal,
dass es in Los Angeles
drei bis acht Monate dauert.
Woanders kann es
zwei, drei Jahre dauern.
Nach letzten Checks
nimmt er seinen Kampf gegen
die städtische Bürokratie wieder auf.
* Schwere, elektronische Musik *
Der Verkehr schlängelt sich weiter,
ohne Unterbruch.
Gut, dass Randy Nerven aus Stahl hat
und in bester Begleitung ist.
Randy, seit wann kennen wir uns?
Seit Juni 2002, seit 17 Jahren.
17 lange Jahre. Ich habe Randy
als Fahrer kennengelernt.
Wir stehen uns sehr nahe.
Er gehört zur Familie.
Wir gehen zusammen essen, er
lädt mich an meinem Geburtstag ein,
oder an Silvester
zu sich nach Hause.
Wir waren schon zusammen
an Konzerten.
Kurzum: Unsere Beziehung
ist freundschaftlich,
nicht nur geschäftlich.
Wenn meine Tochter
nachts spät ausgeht,
wollen wir nicht, dass sie
ein Uber oder ein Taxi nimmt.
Wir wollen, dass Randy sie abholt.
Wenn meine Frau und ich
zu einem Konzert
oder an eine Abendveranstaltung
gehen und 20'000 Menschen dort sind,
kommen wir raus und wissen,
dass Randy genau beim Ausgang steht.
Manchmal sage ich, wenn ich
einem guten Fahrer begegne ...
Dann erzähle ich dir:
"Ich bin Randy aus Mexiko
oder Randy aus Korea begegnet."
Ist das ein neuer Anzug?
- Nein.
Du bist immer piekfein.
- Er kommt gerade aus der Reinigung.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Die Kehrseite der Medaille
ist für Roger,
dass er gegen den Amtsschimmel
ankommen muss.
Wir gehen ins City of Los Angeles
in Van Nuys.
Das ist das building department,
wo wir ein Meeting
mit einem plan checker haben,
der schaut, ob wir alles
für die Baubewilligung
für das Einfamilienhaus in der Nähe
von downtown Los Angeles haben.
Es ist eigentlich alles viel stärker
reguliert als in der Schweiz,
v.a., wenn's ums Bauen geht.
Ob es ein Vorteil ist,
wenn man Swiss ist?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Man ist on time, man weiss,
wie man mit dem Gesetz umgehen muss,
man ist organisiert -
ja, es ist ein Vorteil.
V.a., weil man gut organisiert ist.
Das ist eigentlich ein Vorteil.
Man lernt in der Schweiz
ja als Kind,
dass man schön organisiert
und on time sein muss.
Ich bin ja auch immer schön
zum richtigen Zeitpunkt da.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass das manchmal nicht hilft,
weil die, mit denen du
zusammenarbeiten musst,
eben nicht on time sind.
Das ist ...
Manchmal kostet es Nerven.
Das Schlimmste, was passieren kann,
ist, dass er sich die Pläne anschaut
und nicht alles da ist, wovon er
glaubt, dass es da sein müsste.
Dann kann er
nicht alles kontrollieren
und schickt uns zurück nach Hause.
Auf in den geheimnisvollen Dschungel
der Stadtverwaltung.
Bekommt Roger endlich
die langersehnte Baubewilligung?
* Fliessende,
klirrende Klaviermusik *
UCLA, ein Campus der Superlative.
Ein über 169 ha grosses Grundstück
in Westwood
mit knapp 45'000 Studierenden
aus der ganzen Welt.
Die Stadt in der Stadt
besteht aus 163 Gebäuden.
Meist wird ein bekannter Architekt
mit einem Neubau betraut.
Für Lauriane
geht die erste Kurswoche zu Ende.
Es gibt 1'000 neue Sachen.
Daran musst du dich erst gewöhnen,
aber alles in allem läuft es gut.
Ich muss mich beeilen,
sonst komme ich zu spät.
Ich finde die Kurse sehr gut.
Sie sind super interessant.
Die Professoren
haben eine Art, zu unterrichten,
die ich
für etwas amerikanisch halte.
Sie bauen Witze ein, sie bieten fast
schon eine Performance, eine Show.
Hier das chinesische Raumschiff,
das auf dem Mond gelandet ist.
Auch die Vereinigten Staaten
haben ein Raumfahrtprogramm,
die EU hat eins, die Russen auch.
Damit machen sie klar:
"Wir sind technisch top."
"Wir können das."
Das ist ein starkes Zeichen,
und die Chinesen
haben ihre Leistungsfähigkeit
der ganzen Welt vorgeführt.
Verwirkliche etwas im All,
und alle werden es sehen,
und alle werden wissen,
dass es alle gesehen haben.
Ein Raumfahrtprogramm
ist ein sehr effizientes Mittel.
Auch die Universität kann prahlen.
Die Namen der Ehemaligen
lesen sich wie der Abspann
eines Hollywood-Klassikers:
Francis Ford Coppola,
Jim Morrison und James Dean,
die wie Lauriane gerade mal
ein Semester hier verbracht haben.
Sylmar, San Fernando Valley,
35 km ausserhalb der Stadt.
Doras Zuhause.
In L.A. heisst es,
das sei ein Randgebiet,
dabei werden hier
keine Autos angezündet,
sondern gehegt und gepflegt.
Das Haus wird wegen des anstehenden
Verkaufs gerade aufgemöbelt.
Hey, guys!
Hunde und Menschen sind
in einem Zimmer zusammengepfercht
und leiden unter den Bauarbeiten.
Das sind mein Eddy und mein Simon.
Ja, wir leben alle hier drin -
vier Hunde und mein Mann.
Wir müssen unbedingt lüften.
Das riecht nicht mehr gut.
Und dieser Rollladen
muss ersetzt werden. Er geht kaputt.
Ihr könnt ganz ruhig sein.
Wir lassen euch nicht zurück,
versprochen.
Ihr kommt mit uns in die Schweiz.
Ihr wart ausgesetzte Tiere,
die ich aufgenommen habe.
Alles wird gut,
das verspreche ich euch.
Das war mal meine Küche.
Im Moment
kann man hier nicht mehr essen.
Wir müssen sie
für den Verkauf vorbereiten.
Die wollen das eigentlich schon
am 1. Februar auf den Markt bringen,
aber ich bin nicht sicher,
dass das geht.
* Langsamer Country-Song *
# I met a girl in New Orleans,
she was waiting on tables there.
I like the guys' song.
- # I told her that I loved her smile
# and her pretty head of hair.
# She invited me
back to her place ...
Who is that?
- ... who could ask for more?
# I jumped up apprehensively ...
What's going on?
Show me what you do!
Doras Mann Pasqual
ist ein Mann des Theaters.
Das Paar arbeitet an einem Film
über die Tätowierkunst.
Das ist ein Maori.
- Wow.
Ist das auch ein Maori?
- Das ist japanisch.
Wunderschön!
# She grabbed a needle and a bottle
of ink and gave me a little smile ...
In all dem Chaos
bewahrt Dora Haltung -
ganz die disziplinierte Tänzerin.
Pasqual hat mit der Vorstellung,
sein Land zu verlassen, mehr Mühe.
Auch gesundheitlich
ist er nicht ganz auf dem Damm.
Entspann die Schultern! Beide!
Ausatmen, das wird dir guttun.
Ich liebe dich.
- Ich liebe dich auch.
Ich will nicht
in Los Angeles alt werden.
Deshalb ist es gut, zu gehen.
Nicht wahr, mein Schatz?
Ich denke, es wird gut.
Ein völlig neuer Lebensplan.
Und ein neues Leben alle 100 Jahre
ist gut für dich.
Weg von den politischen Unruhen
in Amerika, solange wir noch können.
Keiner weiss, was auf uns zukommt.
Bist du nicht froh,
einen Schweizer Pass zu haben?
Sehr froh.
Ich hoffe, ich werde ihm gerecht.
Ich werde mich wohl
an die Sprache anpassen
und sie noch besser lernen müssen.
Ich werde Kurse
an der Migros-Klubschule nehmen,
aber auch mit Babbel
auf dem Handy lernen.
Dank beidem werde ich dann wohl
Grüezi und Ja sagen können.
Jungfrau.
Jufer? - Jungfrau.
- Oh, Jungfer.
Jungfrau.
- Jung-Frau.
That's perfect.
- Ja.
* Einsame Flötenklänge *
In dieser Stadt
brauchen Kämpfer einen langen Atem.
Haben Roger und sein Ingenieur Dean
den Heiligen Gral gefunden?
Pokergesichter
und ein etwas angestrengtes Lächeln.
Man muss
auf die Kleinigkeiten achten.
Sie wollen deine Pläne
noch einmal sehen.
Meine Pläne sind gut.
Es ist nicht schlecht gelaufen.
Architecturally ist alles okay.
Jetzt müssen wir einfach noch
im engineering, also structurally,
for grading and all that
noch einige corrections machen.
Und dann müssen wir
noch einige clearances holen,
also in verschiedenen departments
bestätigen lassen,
dass alles okay ist.
Wir haben es mit verschiedenen
städtischen Abteilungen zu tun.
Einige
nehmen es mit architektonischen,
andere mit Ingenieursregeln
sehr genau.
Einigen ist es komplett egal,
andere wollen am liebsten
gar nichts bauen lassen.
Aber damit müssen wir leben.
Okay, see you over there.
* Wehmütige Klänge *
In Los Angeles regnet es nie,
das weiss jeder.
Aber nach jahrelanger Dürre
wird im Regen getanzt und gesungen.
Die Wassertanks füllen sich
und die Autos glänzen.
(Weibliche Computerstimme)
In quarter of a mile,
turn right on North Figueroa Street.
Mist, wir haben einen Umweg gemacht.
* 80er-Jahre Hip-Hop-Song:
"Buffalo Gals" von Malcolm McLaren *
# Two Buffalo gals go around
the outside, round the outside ...
Das erinnert mich an meine Jugend.
Francesca muss 1 Std. fahren,
um ihre Söhne Milo und Tristan von
der internationalen Schule abzuholen.
Europäischer Lehrplan mit Unterricht
auf Englisch und Französisch,
um das Niveau zu halten.
Salut.
- Salut.
Tristan, wie geht's deinen Füssen?
Sind sie nass?
Brauchst du ein anderes Paar Schuhe?
Müssen wir dir für heute Abend
neue Schuhe kaufen?
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Letzter Stopp des Tages für Randy
bei seiner Firma,
wo er seine Limousine abstellt.
Der Betrieb ist auf Dienstleistungen
für VIPs spezialisiert.
Tschau, Marcus, ich bin fertig.
Bis morgen.
Okay, thank you.
Ich bin ständig unterwegs.
Wenn ich kann, spiele ich Football
oder gehe an den Strand.
Ich arbeite und bin sehr aktiv.
Schlafen kann ich, wenn ich tot bin.
* Fliessender Indie-Rocksong *
In den Hügeln von Los Feliz
bei Hollywood,
in der Nähe des grössten
Wassertanks der Stadt, Silver Lake.
Das Viertel
ist ein wahrer Künstlerpool.
Hier wohnt Francesca
mit ihrer Familie.
Nehmt die Papiere mit, Jungs!
Attends une seconde!
Hi!
Ich habe drei Hündinnen,
drei bitches.
Ich brauche hier weibliche Energie.
Um mich herum habe ich nur Macker.
Ich habe einen Mann und zwei Söhne.
Es riecht nach Käsefüssen,
und der Klodeckel ist ständig oben.
Deshalb brauche ich weibliche
Energie von meinen Hündinnen.
Yeah, that's my beauty.
Das sind Fotos, die Cathy Opie
von meinen Kindern gemacht hat.
Im Gegenzug
hat sie ein Bild bekommen.
Wir haben getauscht.
Sie möchte sie
noch einmal fotografieren.
Das wäre super,
jetzt, wo sie Teenager sind.
Und das ist ein Bild
von Eddies Vater, Ed Ruscha.
Er war ein grossartiger Mann.
Und das ist ein Foto von Eddie,
seinem Vater und Milo.
Der Schwiegervater
ist ein bekannter Pop-Art-Künstler,
der Ehemann und die Kinder
sind Musiker.
Ganz einfach eine kreative Familie.
Ich mache heute Abend Burger.
Ich befolge ganz genau
das Schweizer Rezept für Burger.
Ich denke, wir sollten zuerst
das Gemüse machen.
Was meine Kunst angeht, konnte ich,
als ich noch keine Kinder hatte,
in meinem Atelier bleiben,
auch bis Mitternacht.
Ich konnte arbeiten.
Das ging problemlos.
Aber jetzt geht das nicht mehr.
Deshalb müssen wir uns
ein bisschen besser organisieren,
damit beides klappt.
Gleichzeitig
sollte keines von beidem leiden,
weil die Kinder dich brauchen.
Wir versuchen,
die Dinge gut zu machen,
so, wie wir es für richtig halten,
und trotzdem unsere Identität
als Künstler zu bewahren.
Es kann dazu führen, dass du
deine Kunst anders fokussierst.
Ich glaube, es war
in vielen Dingen sogar hilfreich,
Kinder zu haben, und dadurch eine
breitere Perspektive auf das Leben
und auf unseren Platz in der Welt.
Tatsächlich bietet Kalifornien
für mich eine Art Freiheit,
sogar für den eigenen Lebensstil,
für die Art, wie du lebst,
die Art, einen offeneren Blick
auf die Dinge zu haben.
Ich wurde in der Schweiz erzogen
und das war gut, aber es war anders.
Es war etwas eng.
Die Prüfung hat drei Teile.
Redet ihr über Malcom X?
- Wahrscheinlich.
Und sicher über
Martin Luther King Jr.
Die Schwarzen Panther.
- And the Black Panthers.
Ich habe einen wunderbaren Film
von Agnes Varda gesehen.
Ja, den hast du mir gezeigt.
Wir sollten ihn uns
heute Abend anschauen.
Sie war so jung und klein, aber sie
hat die Schwarzen Panther gefilmt.
Fernab vom Hollywood-Glamour
liegt North Hollywood,
ein bescheidenes Viertel,
in dem die Strassenlaternen
die Spotlights sind.
Los Angeles ist eine riesige Stadt -
nicht wie Lugano,
wo ich aufgewachsen bin,
mit meinem Umfeld,
meinen Freunden, den Nachbarn.
Ich fühle mich hier nicht allein.
Es ist kein Problem,
dass ich ledig bin,
dass ich keine Familie habe,
weil ich ständig unter Leuten bin.
* Zischende Lockgeräusche
für Katzen *
Wenn ich zu Hause bin oder hier,
mag ich die Nähe zu den Tieren,
die ich liebe.
Ich liebe das Leben, weil ich
tun und lassen kann, was ich will.
Roger!
* Lockgeräusche *
* Friedliche Klaviermelodie *
Manchmal, da gab es so Momente
im Lauf des Jahres,
zu Weihnachten oder Neujahr.
Ich hatte niemanden, wusste nicht,
wohin, und blieb allein zu Hause.
Es gab Momente der Einsamkeit
in dieser grossen Stadt.
In der Stadt der 1'000 Lichter
lauert die Einsamkeit im Schatten.
Sie wittert ihre Beute,
bereit sie zu verschlingen.
Wer in L.A. überleben will,
muss die Einsamkeit besiegen.
* Pulsartige Paukenschläge *
Man sieht die Häuser in Flammen
und v.a. die enorme Masse Rauch,
die über die Stadt kommt.
Wie kann ich das darstellen?
Wir sind offiziell verspätet.
An alle Männer:
Blumen sind immer gut.
Hallo.
- Hallo, Schatz.
550 ist mein Mindestpreis.
Wenn wir das erreichen wollen,
brauchen wir eine Strategie.
* Fliessende Popmusik *